after different Green Deal announced
yesterday by the Commission after the
cup 25 we take the stone commitment we
want Europe as the first climate neutral
continent we took this decision with
respect for many concerns of different
countries because we know that it is
important to take into consideration the
different national circumstances and
also different starting point we think
also it is important to show all the
possible efforts in in order to take
into consideration the social
consequences and we have also taken into
consideration the fact that for one
member states it is necessary to take
more time before they implement this
objective and we left the occasion by
June 2020 to come back in the council
regarding this country it is very
important because we know that we have
to discuss many difficult and sensitive
topics regarding the next European
budget for example the level of ambition
for example the we base the
conditionality the balance between the
classical policies on the one hand and
the new policies on the other hand
climate change for example is a very
important issue in this framework the
own resources and also we can see that
it is important to have a close
cooperation with European Parliament
because you can pound is also able to
play in order to in order to be able to
take this decision
it was very interesting to see the
leaders endorsing and supporting the
complex European Green Deal we've been
debating all the opportunity brings
along of course we know that the reason
for the effort of the European Green
Deal is destructive climate change we
see but we are determined to tackle this
climate change and turn it into an
opportunity for the European Union
knowing that right now the European
Union is front-runner in that topic and
we want to stay that be the front-runner
we want to stay to be the role model
here but of course we are aware that not
every region has the same starting point
we are aware of the fact that some have
to come along a way that for some
regions and sectors it will be more
difficult to adapt and to have the
turning point therefore we have been
debating how to support people companies
and regions better that have today adapt
stronger I'm very keen to work very
closely with the Member States on the
agenda of the European Green Deal it
will be now up to the Commission to
present in January our proposal for the
sustainable Europe investment plan
combined with the just transition
mechanism and then in March we will
propose the first climate law so that we
develop slowly but surely the roadmap
that have we have laid out in the
communication we adopted yesterday
in the college
it is very important that the budget has
to reflect our political priorities as
well as the strategic agenda of the
council as still quite some work to do
to reach that goal but what we need now
is a quick agreement between the Member
States because time is pressing
therefore I'm very grateful for the
dynamics and the initiative you took on
right now I'm very much looking forward
to work with you on that
so in close cooperation I hope that we
will have a very soon a good result I
see thank you and see you tomorrow Yuko
resumes at 9:30